Hi.
I'm very excited to be here.  Thank you.
OK
From about 1995-96 until about 2002, I had the
the great fortune of being the host of Nickelodeon's Blue's
Blue's Clues.  I see
I see many of you were five in 1998.
It was a it was
a very very very wonderful thing. But that was kind of an interesting reaction there because you
either know that show, or you totally don't know that show.
It afforded me a sort of
rare thing, I called it micro celebrity. Because I wasn't famous, really.
I would tell everybody that I was fameish
which, which is
actually different. I would say that, you know, being... Fameish people are like
famous people without the public dignity.
dignity that is involved in being actually famous. So.
For the uninitiated:
Blue's Clues was an animated children's television
show. Wherein I would
galavant, if you will, with a magical animated blue puppy. And I would talk
to salt shakers and bars of soap
And
I'm completely unrecognizable now. But the way I looked then
imagined I had lime
green socks on and, uh, really embarrassing pleated
pants and, um
a striped Polo shirt that I wore in every single
episode and hair
like Lego helmet hair. And I was
yopey and dopey and so excited about absolutely everything.
And I had this giant red chair that I couldn't wait to sit in
all the time. And when the mail showed up, I froke out.
Like, just
froke out. I would, I would leap into the air and start gambling about like
a lamb and just like swinging my arms
And I would sing this crazy song and I would freak out and then I would scream like PeeWee Herman
at the AHHH-AHHHH!
It was
crazy. And it was awesome but it
was it was not exactly the kind of thing that I would think would ever get me a
date.
But it was great. And it was all to wonderful effect because the show was incredibly well thought
out and it was, it was incredibly educational and my favorite part of the show my job on the
show was to talk directly through
the camera. And and to actually cultivate, if I could a
relationship with with an individual child through a T.V.. The conceit being that
that that I can hear them.
And that they can hear me.
And that's tricky and what we found out is that it totally worked.
And kids
thought I was their friend - for real.
Like millions of them.
And I thought.
Oh, wow.
Because the show actually became very popular and
despite how wonderful it was, the more popular it became, the more that started to weigh on me.
For real, I started to think
Well, I'm saying these wonderful things to kids. I'm saying, you know, "You are so smart" and "You can
do anything that you want to do" but I couldn't help thinking, you
know, is that true?
Am I saying the right things to all of these children? It felt like a
really tremendous responsibility. And on top of that, my name on the show was Steve, and my name in
real life is Steve.
And it was becoming this sort of thing where people assumed
I created the show or that I was Fred Rogers and, in some way. And it was this
indelible thing like I wore the same shirt every time, it was like a very
iconic iconic thing on purpose. And it was in multiple countries now.
And I had moved to New York
to be Serpico, really, you know.
You know I was either going to I was I moved to New York I was going to fail privately or
I was going to be Al Pacino and that was it. For real and now
this thing was
happening. And it was getting huge and, well, I didn't expect any
of this I didn't even know any children when I moved to New York,
you know. I I I'm I'm I'm really worried I'm like am I the right guy for this job?
this job? I took it really really seriously. And my contract was up for
renewal and I was starting to really seriously think. As great as this is I thought they might have
the wrong gu here
guy here. You know and maybe this should be a teacher or a child development specialist
or
something and I was. I was very very conflicted about it and I was seriously thinking. I'm having an
identity crisis and maybe I shouldn't do this and um
then I became one of People magazine's most eligible
bachelors.
And that sounded good. You know I'm
the nerd from high school. Obviously And so that was wonderful and I thought that was the greatest thing in
the world. I took the magazine to bars with
me.
Like I wanted to make T-shirts, like I was just like, whoa!
And so then we
started getting fan mail like we've never gotten fan mail before. You know from from ladies and it
was very
different and and and Nickelodeon kept a lot of that from me but. But one of them made it
to my desk. And I opened it and
it was. It was an eight by ten glossy of an incredibly gorgeous woman in a swimsuit.
I was like, Wow. She could be a swimsuit model I flipped it over and there was a letter and she was a swimsuit model.
And she had been in Playboy. She was a Playboy model. And this is her phone
number and, We should have dinner sometime I'm in the
area. And I'm like I can't do that she's clearly an axe murderer and this
isn't real. So I didn't I didn't call her but I did hang it on on my office
door and and, Because it was funny you know and
it and it stays there for a long time and stay there for like a month two months or something and then I heard
a knock on my office door. And I opened it up, and there's like,
Half of the animators out there.
Now the animators. Those are my friends at Blue's Clues right. The animators. They're nerds.
They're total nerds. They live in caves and they like move pixels
around and they, and they shun the light. They're the nerds they're my
people, right, and they're deadly serious, and they're pointing to the picture, and they're like
you have to call her.
For
us.
And it's clear they don't mean for them they mean for me and them because we are the same and then,
at that moment I realize, yes this is my John Hughes moment, and I have to call the Playboy model, how do you not do that
not do that. So I call her and she's really who she says she is and
you know and I'm really me. And you know, we're not axe murderers and yeah we're going to go to a fancy restaurant.
We decide to go on a really fancy date. I'm going on a date with a Playboy model! And
she asks me to send a limo. And
I suggest
I suggest well, maybe I could pick you up in my Volkswagen Beetle.
And we can drop the car off in Brooklyn and take a car to the city, hows that? You know and she's like Well
that sounds great too. So she lives in New Jersey, so I'm driving to New
Jersey, terrified, I've got flowers. I'm like,
behind the wheel and I've got the ghost of like thirty animators in the back
the back seat of my Beatle with me. Stayed focused, Steve.
Don't let us down, so
I drive all the way out to Jersey in the suburbs and I knock on her door and she opens the
door. And she's at least six feet tall.
And she has giant fake boobs. Just giant.
And they weren't in the swimsuit picture so they're clearly new and clearly not real and clearly fake
and clearly giant
giant. And they're here, like
for real. And. And I
and I
honestly thought I was going to be suave and like and go in for the kiss on the cheek and give her the flowers and we'd be off but
I couldn't like
I was coming in under the radar. So I shake
her hand and I'm looking up at her and she's looking down at
me like oh boy, and you know she's wearing tight acid washed jeans and
red pumps and and and a glittery leopard print tank
top and I'm like. Whoa. And It's immediately awkward. And
like well, shall we...she's like 'Yeah.'
So we go to my car, we sit in the car and I'm putting on my seatbelt
and she stares straight ahead and just says 'I thought you'd be taller.'
And I click my seatbelt and said, 'so did I.'
(Laughter) So now
I'm having a panic attack and I'm like how can I save this
because the truth is she's really really beautiful and its a Playboy model and, you know.
This is
my one shot at this for sure, you know. I've got to make this right, for the animators and me.
So as I'm pulling out of a cul-de-sac I notice
on a mailbox a balloon a blue balloon. And then I notice on another mailbox another blue balloon leading up to
another mailbox with a bunch of paw prints on it.
and a sign underneath it that said you just figured out Jonathan's birthday. Clearly someone
in her neighborhood was having a Blues Clues themed birthday party. In my car,
at that moment I had a box of toys, Blue's Clues toys, some autographs and the
Outfit. From Blue's Clues.
And I thought. Believe it or not.
This is the only game you
have man. (Cheers)
So.
I looked at her and as suavely as I could. Would you mind?
And she was great
she was like, no, that would be awesome, I know these guys' come on lets do it, so I put on the outfit. And
I get the toys and I walk into Jonathan's backyard, he's having a birthday party with a Carvel
cake. And I'm like hey who's Johnathan. Happy birthday! And the
freak
freak out. The mom freaks out, and the Dad's like, who is this man? Ya know?
And she's
great she runs she runs interference. She's like 'no that's really him' I'm your neighbor. And we have an awesome time
for like twenty minutes and these kids are awesome. And like I'm making this kid's life. It's fantastic.
Now we've got something to talk about right so we're in the car and everything's great. We drop the car off we go to
the restaurant. And the first thing that happens is I walk in with her.
And there's. There's
a couple right here and it's a married couple, and the guy looks at me recognizes me
me clearly. And I watch him say to his wife, that's Steve from Blue's Clues.
And he's with an escort.
(Laughter)
And I'm thinking, 'Oh yeah that's exactly what this looks like, exactly
what this looks like.'
So we sit down to have dinner and now we're trying to talk to each other
we've got absolutely nothing in common, She's incredibly negative she hates the restaurant, she picked it.
She hates it. It was impossible to get a reservation there. She hates the food, she orders a steak,
And then orders A1 at the restaurant, hates the wine, she's kind of mean.
And, and like we've got nothing to talk about and I'm regretting the whole thing, and this is a terrible disappointing
experience so I'm just drinking
just like drinking, trying to get through this and the animators in my head are drunk too. And they're like,
What are you doing don't mess this up for me, you have to keep going, don't ruin this.
So it's the end of dinner and she's like I well, I want to see your place.
And I did it and I was like
oh OK. OK. Yes. Yes. Shut down enough parts of my brain now
now
that, that I can do this. So we get back to my place and I've got
that big red chair from the show in my house. They gave it to me on my birthday it's awesome, right?
and it happens to be
to be at my house. She's like, oh, sit in the chair let me take some pictures!  And I was like, no I don't want to sit in the chair, the
means different things to me
You know,
So I am, so I'm sitting in the chair eventually, and she's like well, I know what you do.
What I actually do other than model is, I'm a stripper.
And I'm like, OK...
OK. Right OK that's fine. Because I'm a kids show host.
Everybody's got to do something. And she says would you mind if I show you what
I do. And I'm like no.
OK now this is going to be cool, you know, because like this, you know fourteen
year old Steve, this is great to him, this is like fantastic I can, this is exciting. So.
All right fine.
And I think my God. You know. I'm going to see my first fake boobs. It's going
to be wonderful and it wasn't at all, it was terrible and weird and.
They look like boobs that were designed by Dr Seuss, or something
I'm sure that there are
great ones but that was just like so awful and so weird.  And she's doing her dance
and then she comes up to me and I'm in the chair and she's like, sing that song about the
(gasps)
And I said. No I'm not going to sing the song. And she starts
getting very demanding. She's like come on, sing it sing it, and I'm like.
No and it's very clear to me that it's an ultimatum with her. Right she's saying, sing that
about the mail or this is over. And at that moment even the nerds in my head
said, 'walk away man, just
Just, walk away man, there's, there's
there's no winning here, no one's going to win. You know, just, just walk away.
But I was wasted at this point, she's drunk so
I can't get her home so she has to stay and it's terrible and it's awkward. And I drive her back the next morning
and I'm dropping her off and she says. My mother wants to meet you. And I'm like 'you live with your
mom, you're like... So she lives with her mom and her mom comes she's like you know,
You must be Steve. Have a cup of coffee.
And I'm sitting there in their living room and her mom's got a manila folder. And she
opens it and she starts handing me
drawings. And, it turns out that much of this was an elaborate plot,
To pitch me a children's television show
about giant inflatable
inflatable balloon animals. Called the Bloonies.
And
it was just awful and all I wanted to do was go home, but I couldn't because I had to drive from there to the airport.
I was doing a Make a Wish event that, uh that that afternoon. Now I
had done a lot of work with Make A Wish before, um I don't usually
talk about, something I don't usally talk about, but for those who don't know what it is, it's for.
very unhappy or often dying children. They get to choose one
thing. Right. And this organization makes that wish happen. Now, I got to do a lot of
and um,
The thing that is always striking about it is no matter how awful the circumstances are
for the kid
kid. No matter what they're going through they immediately.
as an opportunity to make their parents happy. Yeah.
And this was another one just like that. And uh,
this is complicated for me because I also am aware that this child choose me
Right?
Right. Like me. That's what they want. And I'm not sure what me
Am
me. Am I Steve Burns, am I Steve with the shirt whose me?
I don't know which one it is, right, so it's really complicated. But
that helped me realize
realize that, whether I wanted it to be true or not whether I expected
to be true or not the answer was 'both.'
and that was plenty cool enough
for me.
Thank you Thank you Lou.